Lots of times when,
when I'd been treating people for depression,
for example,
or anxiety,
they have existential issues.
You know what,
it's not just some psychiatric condition.
It's not just the third tapped off of normal because their brain chemistry is
faulty.
Although,
you know,
sometimes that happens to be the case.
It's that they are overwhelmed by the suffering and complexity of their life and
they're not sure why it's reasonable to continue with it.
You know,
that they can feel that terrible negative meanings of life,
but are skeptical beyond belief about any of the positive meanings.
I had one client who was a very brilliant artist and as long as he didn't think
he was fine,
you know,
because he'd go and create and who is really good at being an artist,
he just,
you know,
he had that personality that was continually creative and quite brilliant.
Although he was self denigrating and,
but as soon as he started to think about what he was doing,
then,
you know,
the,
it's like a,
like a drill or a thought or something like that.
He'd saw the branch off that he was sitting on because he'd start to criticize
what he was doing.
Even the utility of it,
even though it was sort of self evidently useful,
and then he would be,
then it would be very,
very hard for him to even motivate himself to create.
And He,
I,
he always struck me as a good example of,
of
the consequences of having your rational intellect divorced in some way from
your being divorced enough so that it actually questions the utility of your
being.
And it's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing and it's,
it's really not a good thing because it manifests itself not only an individual
psychopathology but also in social psychopathology.
And that's his proclivity of people to get tangled up in etiology.